okay so like real talk
um it's been a rough month one of those
things that I discovered was all of a
sudden boy became a great way to digest
whatever emotions I was going through in
the course of a day
[Music]
yeah I'm not gonna lie that ribbon
dancing was pretty cool all of us want
to find our people all of us want to
find connection put up their friends
so may is mental health awareness month
I almost missed it which is kind of
ironic partially because my own mental
health has been a little bit of a
challenge this month but I did want to
Mark the occasion by talking about
something that's near and dear to me as
a flow artist and that is the impact
that flow Arts has on my mental health
and specifically how it can help improve
it Drex here from Drex Factor Poise
sharing with you the love of boy
spinning and flowers to benefit your
body and brain and today we're going to
dive into the brain side of things
because I want to share how flow arts
does benefit my brain and hope that it
can for you too but before we dive in I
just want to give a quick shout out to
the Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyroterra light
toys spin balls and Ultra POI for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all of these awesome companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links that I have down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non-business Friends of
the channel Lane machinsky and Becca
beckonen thank you both so much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission
so as I'm recording this video it is
Saturday May 20th and uh I am coming off
a couple weeks that have been incredibly
challenging from a mental health
perspective for a variety of reasons and
it is also the day that there is a
massive Street Festival down near the
Capitol Building here in DC called
Fiesta Asia that is a pan-Asian
celebration of culture food live
entertainment Etc so what are those
things I'm doing for my mental health
today is to go out and take part in that
so how about y'all join me so I did some
thinking and I've realized that there
are five specific ways that flow Arts
helps to improve my mental health I'm
going to share the first of them with
you as I'm on my way to go grab a bike
and head down to the Metro first up and
this is honestly a pretty obvious one
but there's the physical activity side
of things there are so many studies out
there showing now that physical activity
is something that can have a positive
impact on Mental Health whether you
struggle with depression anxiety or any
number of other conditions I do want to
put a little bit of a pin in this one
though because one of the most frequent
ways that people kind of Gaslight or
tell people that are suffering from
disorders like depression that they
could be doing more to improve their
condition is to ask if they've gone out
and done any physical activity and there
are some days when quite frankly just
getting out of bed is the Victory and I
don't want to I I don't want to cast
aspirations on that
if you're in a place where just getting
out of bed is the victory for the day or
you can't even do that then you know
what that is a valid place to be
but at the same time as a flow artist
being able to get out and engage in
physical activity on a frequent basis is
absolutely something that has a positive
impact on my state of mind and something
I really appreciate about being a flow
artist one of those things that I found
was really helpful for keeping my mental
health in a positive place during the
quarantine was making sure that I had a
regular routine of getting out at the
end of each day and flowing for an hour
regardless of what that flow consisted
of just so long as I engaged in it I
really do not think it is underrated at
all just to make flow a regular part of
your routine regardless of how intense
it is regardless of you know whether
you're learning a lot of new tricks or
what have you just engaging in the
activity itself is helpful all right
cool so I am arriving at the bikes so
I'm gonna go hop a bike and then hop on
the Metro and I'll see you all on the
other side there
Peace So as is not infrequently the case
in DC the Metro is kind of a mess today
so I'll give you my second Point here
while we're waiting for the train to
come in
so second way that I find that flow Arts
is a great fit for helping out with
mental health is a term that's kind of
become a little bit of a buzzword and
that is mindfulness so as I understand
it mindfulness is basically fixing the
brain in the moment that is rather than
having your brain obsessed with
something that is off in the future or
somewhere far off that is away from you
it brings your mind into the present in
a way that makes it so that it's more
difficult to catastrophize as somebody
who suffers from a lot of anxiety you
know that's something that's really
really important to me cool trains here
let's get started
[Music]
oh
all right so as I was saying before this
actually came up recently because I was
actually at one of the Smithsonian
museums the American Indian Museum and
learning some cool indigenous skill toys
and one of the people that was
presenting one of those skill toys kind
of pointed out to me that when you're
working on a task that is you know it
might not be completely beyond your
grasp but it takes some concentration it
focuses you in the now in a way that
really grounds you and that I feel like
there are very few things out there that
ground people in the same kind of way
so yeah I'm going to call Flow Arts a
win when it comes to mindfulness and
grounding all right so I have made it
downtown I just got off at the Judiciary
Square stop which for some reason is
always pronounced with a British accent
in my head I'm not sure why but now I am
on my way down to the street festival so
hopefully it is still popping and as I'm
walking down there I'll talk about the
third thing that I think flow Arts is
really good for that helps with my
mental health and this one might be a
little bit more uniquely me but I feel
like flow Arts gives me a sense of
purpose so like running my channel is
one of those things that I get to have a
pretty direct impact on a lot of people
out there I see people learning the
things that I've taught them and it
makes me really happy I love knowing
that I'm giving people something that is
improving their lives too plus which
having regular goals that I'm attempting
to make with my flow whether it be
creating content or whether you know it
be trying to get down a piece of
choreography by X time you know having
to do that stuff on a regular basis
keeps me in a routine and that's also
good for my mental health this gets
talked about a lot where like if you
have regular routines of different
things they can also help ground you
especially with anxiety and depression
and you know not only being a flow
artist but also having a series of
content channels centered around that is
really really helpful for building
routine
[Music]
we're here
yeah so it is really really sunny and
hot out right now which is kind of funny
because apparently we're expecting rain
later on today but I'm going to enjoy
the sunlight while it lasts
[Music]
please
yeah I'm not gonna lie that ribbon
dancing was pretty cool there may be a
thing or three that stuck out of my head
that I might try to do with some POI
we'll have to see all right so the
fourth way that flowers can be helpful
with mental health and again this is I
think somewhat unique to my style of
flow but uh one of those things that I
discovered as I was getting deeper into
POI as dance was all of a sudden boy
became a great way to kind of digest
whatever emotions I was going through in
the course of a day I'd put on some
music and I would find a mood that I
didn't know that I was having and I was
just able to inhabit that mood for a
while which felt really good man it is
pretty noisy all over the place here I'm
gonna see if I can find somewhere to sit
down and finish at this point all right
so I'm going to take a little stroll
through the courtyard of the National
Gallery of Art I've always loved these
fountains and the glass pyramids on the
other side of them so like I realized in
talking about this that it's probably
likely to be somewhat controversial
because I think there are some people
that have a theory of mental health that
like the whole point of it is to get rid
of emotions that may be troubling us and
I am not of that persuasion I think that
every emotion is valid though not every
response to an emotion may be
appropriate and that like the more we
feel those things and the more we
acknowledge and process those things the
better we do overall so being able to
flow out to be able to inhabit whatever
I'm feeling in a given day be it you
know frustration or joy
sometimes it's loneliness all of it I
think has a place and I really enjoy
being able to flow and dance in order to
explore all of those feelings
foreign
[Music]
I would really really love to grab some
of the food or drinks but all of the
bloody concession lines are so long
we'll see if I uh break down and go get
in one anyhow but in the meantime let's
talk about item number five shall we
okay so honestly this one might be the
simplest one of all and that's just
connection through flow Arts we find
people that we like we find support we
find people that are there for us when
we are at our lowest and that's not
nothing that is something that has been
a big help to me in the past year for
the first time I think in my entire life
I've put some effort into leaning on the
people around me and let them know how
they can support me all of us want to
find our people all of us want to find
connection we want to find our home we
want to find our family we want to find
our tribe and flow Arts is honestly a
great way to do that because as one
person once told me you find other
people that are willing to go out and
spin around an object and figure out how
to do tricks with it you all have
something in common
I think it takes a special kind of
person to do that so flow Arts is great
for connecting people who have that gear
in their head and helping them to find
each other literally we send up a flag
to alert each other when we're around
and it's kind of cool so check it out
this spot behind me here is the Canadian
embassy for some reason the Canadians
went really really hard on having a
presence here in the United States and
they have this beautiful Courtyard and
rotunda I've actually shot videos here
previously being in the shade feels so
nice uh goodness gracious me definitely
like always bring water hydrate their
dear friends
okay so like real talk um it's been a
rough month and yet at the same time
I'm feeling surprisingly on top of
things some pretty awful stuff has
happened but like I feel as though I'm
able to engage with life I feel like I'm
able to maintain meaningful
relationships I feel like I'm able to
keep myself focused at work which kind
of means a lot and there's a lot of
different factors that led into that not
just going to therapy and learning new
tools for being able to support myself
and others when mental health becomes a
problem but you know also too flow Arts
plays a role in all that and I'm really
grateful to have it in my life so a very
happy mental health awareness month to
all of you out there uh pretty please
tell me your stories about flow arts and
mental health how has flow Arts
supported your mental health over the
years please leave me a comment and let
me know if you got anything out of this
video please make sure to give it a like
share comment and subscribe to keep the
conversation going to help other people
find it and of course to help my channel
grow
thank you
foreign
would not be possible we're not for the
kind support of all of these awesome
people right here these are my flow
patrons over on patreon they and the
people listed down in the description
helped to make this video and all the
videos on this channel possible thank
you one and all for your very generous
support and if you out there watching
are not currently a supporter but you'd
like to become one you can do so by
heading out over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up you can do
that hit the link that I've got down in
the description or the cards you just
popped up if you're watching on YouTube
there you can get access to a whole host
of awesome rewards and even better
you'll be helping me out in my mission
to bring POI spinning and flow Arts to
the whole wide world go check that out
please and thank you and if you'd like
to check out some of my other videos on
Flow arts and mental health and
specifically my own mental health I'm
going to go ahead and leave a link to a
playlist of those videos down in the
description as well as up here on screen
if you're watching on YouTube also the
YouTube algorithm thinks that you might
like this top video here based upon your
past viewing habits and stuff that other
people who watch my channel enjoy uh
thank you so much for watching make sure
sure to get out and flow today it's good
for your brains and I'll see you in the
new video real soon peace